[Applause]
all right
let's welcome kevin smith and mark
bernard
man beyond
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
i feel like i feel like chappelle at a
foo fighters concert
for the first time in 15
[ __ ] months and change good people of
los
angeles of hollywood california
of the scum and villainy cantina welcome
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith
[Applause]
[Music]
now what the [ __ ] were we talking about
uh
oh yeah snyder cut [ __ ] no
i don't believe it really exists though
uh welcome back kids holy [ __ ] we've
been talking about this for a [ __ ]
red hot minute
look at this deadpool we're all [ __ ]
man
i'm trusting everyone has their shots
what did you do was there any protocol
whatsoever or was devil may care
what is this dance is safe word a safe
word to this [ __ ] yeah
if you see somebody without a mask they
have promised me
[ __ ] hollywood and you're working on
the merit system
trust these guys look trustworthy right
aren't you trustworthy fair enough man i
mean that guy
i don't know about him
all right don't brag he's like i've been
poked i've been poked too
many times um how is everybody doing
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
what a [ __ ] dream to be able to come
back here there were moments where it
looked like oh [ __ ] we'll always be
doing this online but
uh here we are man so yay science and
[ __ ] like that
um thank you for your patience uh
tonight we've got
so much to [ __ ] do so much [ __ ] to
give away
uh yes we've received so many free
things and they're piled behind us so
we'll be dolling that out as the night
uh goes along
look at all this [ __ ] to [ __ ] touch
you gotta touch him i know like one year
ago we'd have been like
[ __ ] you but now it's like give me it
i'm gonna lick this [ __ ] that's how
confident i am in my [ __ ] vaccination
and [ __ ] and they're like what booster
oh [ __ ]
um how you been man i'm doing all right
man i'm doing all right
you've not been in front of people in a
minute i did a few live shows over the
break and stuff
i was i was cheating on you but i i've
been in front of people how does it feel
to be in front of people
uh it feels great
but also a little weird
but great though still like i'm in the
best shopping mall
right now is how i feel like oh [ __ ]
there's things i like in here
i don't trust anybody but i like it
though
it's weird i didn't i really didn't even
think about the aspect of like oh [ __ ] i
just assumed everybody is like
getting the vaccination but uh like back
east
you know um in the stash we had some i'm
gonna
leave their name out of it but we had
somebody who
wasn't getting the vaccination because i
was like what are we doing mask wise
because we're going
back east to uh do a j and a birthday
event to jamestown bob secret stash in
red bank and then we're also opening
smod castle finally in new jersey which
is right next to quick stop so it's
gonna be amazing and [ __ ] so
in going back i was like what's the mask
policy like are you guys just letting
everybody
in without a mask or whatnot and uh they
were like wow we still have everyone
wearing masks
in the store because one of us didn't
get their
vaccination and i was like what like
[ __ ] this is
my operation man like top down if silent
builds into it you're all [ __ ] into
it man
so i was like who is it and they told me
i was like mother [ __ ] and so uh
i you know jordan was like you can't
make this person get a vaccination by
law and i was like all right but
[ __ ] scoff law i could uh you know i
love [ __ ] batman he don't work within
the confines of the law and [ __ ] so
call me the batman and getting this
[ __ ] idiot vaccinated and so
i i didn't make him do it but i was just
i had another kang
uh carrot to dangle because you can't
[ __ ] with a person's job no no not
against the law but
you can [ __ ] with their desire to have
another job
and i know this person wanted to be in
clerks three real bad so i was just like
hey i can't have you on that set
unless you're vaccinated and you
would not believe [ __ ] the next day
sent me a picture of the [ __ ] card
so at least we got to use [ __ ]
hollywood for something good
uh i i've hopefully i'll be making a
clerks three soon because
i [ __ ] made the dude get vaccinated
so
you know i've been saying this for years
very elaborate ruse just to get this
dude vaccinated
i just now i have to eventually make it
just uh you know i don't know if it's in
the cards we'll see
um what else has been going on [ __ ]
it's been nothing but masters of the
universe for the last uh week and change
since the teaser dropped and stuff uh
we're getting ready to
uh i can't say when but there's another
trailer that's coming that's the story
trailer
uh that has like bear mccreary score
lays out the [ __ ] plot something that
we've not been able to talk about for
oh ever so it'd be nice
to have that interesting two years ago
today we said guess who's got a show
i don't know it was two years ago i'm
just making [ __ ] it was over two years
ago
i remember i was at powercon where we
announced it
and i was like we'll see you all you
know at the end of the year because it
was 2020.
and uh when i got off stage they're like
no no not 2019.
and i was like all right when man how
long does this [ __ ] take they're like 20
21 and i was like what the [ __ ] like
we carving this from stone and [ __ ] like
but it just
won't be here but exactly we didn't that
was before we knew about the [ __ ]
coming pandemic but what a
pandemic-proof business
animation is it didn't matter that
everybody was like holed up inside
the masters of the universe never
[ __ ] stopped it just kept
like like he-man himself our hero who i
swear to god
is our hero in the [ __ ] show oh my
god
that's it's been joyous i honestly like
99.9
of the world is just like this looks
[ __ ] amazing and stuff and knowing
what i know
if you like that teaser like [ __ ]
you'll absolutely adore
the [ __ ] show but there's definitely
been a contingency of folks who
like it's weird like they're trying to
like catch me in like
like supposed lies and [ __ ] like that
because a long time ago somebody asked
me like where somebody put up a tweet
saying hey man
i heard this is what it is and very
specifically in response to that tweet i
said
i promise you it's not that or whatever
the [ __ ] i said but i was speaking very
specific about
uh their outline of the show where they
said i heard the show is about
like [ __ ] uh tila is a better e-man
than he-man so she gets the sword of
power and she's got a girlfriend
and i was like well that sounds great i
wish we you were around when we had the
writer's room going but
i said that's not the story at all and
so i still like stand by that but
there's a bunch of people
like i don't know man this thing smells
[ __ ] woke and [ __ ] and i'm like well
why does it smell woke and hey
why would that be such a horrible thing
and they're like it smells woke because
his [ __ ] teal is in it and i'm like
okay
if you're unfamiliar with the show tila
is literally in every [ __ ] episode
who is the most powerful character in
all of he-man the master's universe like
look at he-man you're like wrong it's
[ __ ]
sorceress so like at the end of the day
this cartoon you claim to love is just
full of [ __ ] [ __ ] that should make
you mad mad from childhood
but uh all we're doing is playing by the
rules that you know are set and
it's crazy because people are like hey
man you're [ __ ] ruining he-man and
i'm like okay
let me just lay out like [ __ ] simple
economics and [ __ ]
logic for folks i know that don't matter
on the internet but whatever the [ __ ]
we'll give it a shot
i got hired by mattel mattel television
to make this [ __ ] okay
mattel makes he-man and the master's
universe line
they don't call it he-man in the masters
universe since its inception and i think
what was it 1981
it's been called masters of the universe
so
they love this [ __ ] and they're trying
to like bring you know their toy line
back into the forefront and
uh somebody wants to go make a movie and
stuff like that so they are so
like wholeheartedly committed to like
launching this in the best possible
[ __ ]
way why on earth would they hire
somebody to be like let me silent bob
this [ __ ] yeah
like it's just it makes no [ __ ] sense
so you know i saw one tweet that killed
me man
like because i want to answer them all
but the folks at netflix are like
stop it just like shut up i swear to god
they're like what are you [ __ ] nuts
like the whole world's happy they're
like you're talking to one person in the
corner i'm like
those are the people that always
fascinate me the most like
i can't help but ever since clerks i
just want to know why not that person so
the one tweet i saw that killed me was
like hey man you said there's a [ __ ]
sequel the he-man in the masters
universe but the word he-man has been
removed from the title
in this real life do you remember like
[ __ ] monty python
and the meaning of life where death came
in and like death is like you're all
[ __ ] dead
and but even better than that like i did
the voice real bad but then
at one point like [ __ ] uh i think
it's michael palin dressed as like a
wife it goes mr
death how did we all die
at the same time and she's so [ __ ]
satisfied like she's like i got
death and he's like the salmon moose and
they're like oh that was the end of it
that's what this [ __ ] tweet reminded
me of like took me right back to my
childhood words it's like
if he-man's name's not in the title
you struck it thus so
and i'm like do you think i have that
much [ __ ] power like i'm a hired hand
they hired me to [ __ ] make a show
and they would not hire me to [ __ ] up a
show i promise you like
i tried and they wouldn't [ __ ] let me
do it so
i don't know i've been dealing with some
of those tweets and stuff but like when
the
story trailer drops everything becomes
clear everything that like i've been
biting my tongue about for like two
years everything we've been going out of
our way not to [ __ ]
spoil you get a general idea of like you
know there's there'll be a big oh
i understand should i not have been
spoiling it
have you been telling [ __ ] hey everybody
what are you telling are you telling me
the truth about how woke it is
i mean i'm just uh it's like he-man in
the wokeness of the universe right
he's like that's the show yes there's
there's one dude who keeps swerving into
my mentions be like so
when are you going to admit that it's a
big bait and switch
and i just keep saying nope everything
that he says
but i have you on record saying this
nope i saw that i saw your tweet it was
just i saw nope
it was in my timeline i was like oh that
can't be good
i clicked on it i was like what about an
interesting classy way to deal with it
really like i'm just not going to engage
yeah just everything he would say just
nope nope
nope yeah your mother sex [ __ ] and hell
nope
thanks that one i'd be like my mom's
still alive i know
but how do you know um yeah it's been
interesting but it hasn't really
dulled the fact that like the overall
the reaction has been like
absolutely wonderful and the the trailer
the story trailer because the teaser
trailer is just literally that
uh will will be coming fairly soon
and it'll illuminate a lot of stuff
indeed uh what you've been working on
other than
[ __ ] taking over hollywood and [ __ ]
i'm trying slowly but surely to
insinuate my way into the
upper echelons of hollywood tell them
what you did i i had launched a
kickstarter
uh about
about a month ago
um thoroughly and totally convinced that
uh that
that i would be humping it across the
finish line um
putting my own money into it disguised
as like various characters from lord of
the rings
like oh [ __ ] gorf and they'll give us
how much money
that's badass um but we
we we earned out in 14 hours we hit our
we had our first goal
90 000 we made in 14 hours which is
[ __ ] nuts
amazing and then we just kept on it
didn't stop i expected like oh he's got
his [ __ ] nut go be happy leave us
alone
but we've we closed the campaign or it
ended however the [ __ ] that works
like three days ago at two hundred and
thirty thousand dollars
wow so that's more than enough to do it
right
that it takes you all the way to the end
that is more than enough to as people
have reminded me
i could make how many clerks for that
much money yeah
that's right what is it how much 230
thousand dollars
10 clerks 10 clerks how tall are you
were 10 clerks tall
each would be a far more well written
and plotted i assure you
um but yeah man so we're making a
[ __ ] short we're starting to to
like hire the people we need to hire
we're starting to negotiate for
like locations and and stage space and
all that stuff and it's remarkable to me
and the dream
was to do it before when the dream was
to do before november 29th i want to
have it
shot by my 50th birthday and you're
going to hit it and we're going to hit
it
look at that [ __ ] unless amazing
unless everything else falls apart
unless some variant who is not working
for the tva
[ __ ] with everything right um i think
it'll happen
[ __ ] a man that has a lot to do
with what sounds like some of the folks
in this room and definitely a lot of
folks
watching at home man there's nothing but
[ __ ] love you've generated
since we've been doing this show and you
know you
gave them a place to point it to put all
that love you were like you know what i
got a [ __ ] dream and they're like oh
[ __ ] here take all my money
i remember at one point thinking like
i'm gonna have to [ __ ] put a lot of
money into this [ __ ] thing
he's gonna be whining like a [ __ ] if he
doesn't make this [ __ ] well i'm also
the guy who's like follow your dreams
and i couldn't stand next to you every
week if you're like my dream was killed
so i was like well i'm putting in
[ __ ] money regardless but you know
obviously mine was but a drop in the
bucket but i got skin in the game
enough to like give you notes and [ __ ]
like that i know i
people are like hey so is kevin going to
be in the movie i was like and can you
cast him in a role where he doesn't say
anything even though he thinks he's
going to come on set with
lines of dialogue and i was like no
because the minute you put kevin smith
in the thing
it's is that [ __ ] kevin smith
especially if i'm wearing this hat
really tough to treat your first film
seriously if i'm like
i was like guys kevin smith boarding a
flight in this church
is this a real airport is this your way
of [ __ ] letting me down in public and
[ __ ]
are you [ __ ] bob sugaring me
that's a jerry maguire reference now you
can be in it
i feel pretty good thanks man i do it
means the world
but yes thank you to everybody who
contributed or everybody who just
[ __ ] shared it
and told people hey you might like this
it uh we don't get to where we got if it
wasn't for the people in this room the
people in that room
and the people out here in the world so
thank you for marvelous
so weird man like are you finding your
sea legs do you remember how to do this
uh we've just been talking to each other
and then jc
for so long and we've been like
practically ignoring jc at this point
it's so weird it's like [ __ ] jc was
our friend when all the cool kids went
away
and now that all the cool kids are back
we just don't really [ __ ] with jc that
much
but he was such an integral and remains
such an integral part of the show but
more importantly
like we're back here in scum and
villainy
with a bunch of [ __ ] bodies there
were times we did the show here
empty like for a while until it got
really sad
and then we were like let's just go home
and do it
we can be in our robes and [ __ ] like
that but um
being back here man with the bar and
you've been open for a minute or two now
but jc was saying before we went this
may be the
highest selling fat man we've ever done
it's uh it's one of the highest selling
fat man and because we're streaming live
to you right now um it might be one of
the biggest
it's probably the biggest audience we've
ever had
for the show happening at the bar which
is pretty nice
[Applause]
it is a metric designed to make us feel
good
yeah we don't know what it means but it
means the world so you're the number one
radio station in drop time in oklahoma
at two o'clock in the morning
number one we did it you guys put that
on a bumper sticker like we can't
too many words um how does it feel to be
back up and running captain
it's uh it's crazy i'm getting a lot of
[ __ ] from youtube about why i'm not
bamfing in
but i i know honestly it's like there
are so many people use i'll bet you
there's a bunch of people
who jumped on to that version of the
show who right now
are like oh they've sold out with this
version of the show
like being completely unfamiliar with it
and stuff yeah man we might have to rock
two versions
i know it's like you thought of that
[ __ ] already
but but but how like one live and one
home show
we're gonna do a bunch of home shows
when you're back in jersey that's true
yeah actually yeah
you got a summer of [ __ ] home shows
coming up
are you gonna do like black man beyond
here
uh
i have to do at least it's true
i have to do at least one because i i
said if we crossed
200 000 dollars on this kickstarter you
will suck the snyder cop
i will i will get these knee pads out
and i will gladly say
here are the things i loved about the
snuggle
uh i will also caution everybody i never
promised how long
said podcast
and we're out thanks everybody it's a
color click
people like ooh get them um you'll do
that maybe do others maybe a couple more
there's also there's a dream about like
while i'm back
east um like i said earlier we opened
smod castle july 9th 10th and 11th so
there's an idea
of me being in smod castle
you being here us with two live
audiences on two different coasts
possible jc banff man
here's your chance [ __ ] jump into the
spotlight
ladies and gentlemen of the bar every
time he bans you got a drink of course
i think that what we do is we set up a
tv
where you are and then we get a tv
at smod castle where mark would be so we
still have this camera shot of you guys
but you're virtual like mark's talking
to your
cyborg counterpart and then we have
tickets we have an audience in jersey
and an audience in here
this is so much longer than i imagined
it would be and more complicated this is
so [ __ ] up and byzantine and whatnot
so wait it requires multiple televisions
and [ __ ] why are we in the 80s all of a
sudden
we were literally doing the show from
our homes and a laptop
but i think it'd be fun if we sold
tickets and mark is here in person
if he can look over at you and your face
is on a tv screen
what about the timing of it it should be
okay it should be pretty close
i'm up for it man sounds like a [ __ ]
disaster but i'm up for it
at the very least what winds up
happening is like kill the feed and we
do two separate shows
on two different coasts and that's it
maybe we can text each other while it's
going up
or it feels like the saddest like
make-a-wish kid thing ever
i think that was me and my virtual
friend who's really not here but let's
go joke
i'll leave one of these hats so you
could wear just in case excellent
so it's represented um yeah man i think
that's ambitious we can pull that off
it'll be
it'll be fun i think there's probably a
version of me going back east to do a
show there
that's absolutely true and then who
knows if you have a weekend off
and you want to come back to la we do a
show here that's true it's not about a
relationship
yeah we can make it work we've been
working oh
how many of you guys would want to come
and sit at scum and villainy and watch
the show
stream live when kevin and mark are
doing it from jersey
[Applause]
jc figuring out how to do it without us
here at all and [ __ ]
it's like two more spaces i could sell
behind the bar
um the state has let you open the place
up full board is that correct
we are yeah back to normal [ __ ] nuts
i remember when we talked about like all
right well what if we just did one where
it's like just the booths
were filled then then that was it they
were real serious about
not having events like when places were
open for the super bowl they're like
our show is very uneventful they're just
talking
they were like no tv so i was like i
don't have any tvs there were like no
events
and i was like well we do events so we
had to cancel everything
until june 15th and then they were like
you can do it again
so and health department came in three
times that week to make sure
that or they came in they checked two
numbers
they came in on like june 9th 10th and
11th to check our numbers and make sure
we are doing everything okay
three days in a row leading up to june
15th i was like why are you guys here
like one last paycheck before it all
goes away what's going on are you ever
in violation
uh not really like we had
we had some like we had like they
measured the tables and they were like
the tables need to be eight feet apart
and yours are seven
foot six it's like june 15th is
tuesday leave me alone and as of june
15th they're like
you can piss in each other's mouths for
all we care
yeah it just you don't get it from seven
inches away
but you don't even have to be that many
inches away anymore right
no we could have a 200 people in here
right now a fire department would have a
problem with it but
we'd be you know if they would have had
a problem
with that wow man so [ __ ] you know
everyone was just like life will never
go back to
normal it literally went back to normal
at least in this room
cut two tomorrow
mark how are you feeling mark banff man
bamf um all right shall we uh
what shall we go to first um well i'm
i'm feeling a little parched i hear that
this year
establishment has uh the finest vineyard
uh
supplying you with content and alcohol i
would like a little wine do you have a
kind of wine that nobody else can get
here
jc ooh do we want carissa can you get
mark a bottle of the new wine we have i
don't either or a glass
bring him the bottle though or the
bottle and a straw because i'm classy
everyone everyone online just found out
mark has a real problem
some are okay with the glass mark's like
oh good thing
how does a rose sound i would love a
rose all right we're gonna bring it out
it's a hot summer night it feels like it
feels like there's a bit being worked
here that i have no idea about
yes is it my birthday
where i get to drink wine sounds like it
um what's you suddenly had a hankering
for wine
well i'm thirsty and i'm in a bar and i
know you're thirsty and wine's gonna
part your thirst
have you ever had wine before you're
gonna need a chaser for that man
i got it no fair enough
[Music]
if i was uh feeling it i'd [ __ ] rock
a
bud seltzer and stuff but can i buy you
one
no i'm already [ __ ] baked i smoked
this [ __ ] joint
that was like pretty pretty insane we
were in the in the green room which is
the alleyway
and uh it was dipped in keith and [ __ ]
it really kicked in once we got up here
i was like oh [ __ ] that's why i probably
got a little saucy on the masters of the
universe stuff i'm like
let me tell you another [ __ ] thing i
got feelings
god i can't wait for him to see it it's
it's
it's really good yeah it's lovely
somebody asked me online today on
twitter they're like
is this the the thing that you're
involved that you think has been the
most or will be the most successful
and i was like well i i i think it's the
thing i've been involved in that'll be
the most
scene that's for damn sure um
in terms of being successful yeah
probably
like i mean i don't know i can make the
argument for clerks pretty successful
i'm still [ __ ]
riding on it like years later almost
three decades later i could still be
like hey remember clerks and at least
like
30 of the room is like kinda
it's a long tail yeah it really is um
all right what shall we do first i mean
we could do some news
do we have an ad to do
oh [ __ ] we could we could do it away
everyone's waiting for it
we could do it can't just talk bam there
you go
it's it is i don't hear you unless you
back
it has a lot more oomph to it with the
with the speakers on in the bar
i feel more in character it's like
you're being mixed by ben burton
i think we do uh i think we do the ad on
saturday i think let's just roll
all right look at you man yeah i'm
holding [ __ ] back it wasn't my decision
it was will wilkins decided
he called it he called it everyone give
it up for will man he spared you an ad
he did
[Applause]
we'll tell you how to shave your balls
or get your dick hard on saturday
whichever one it is
tour words are never spoken uh
shall we dive in to the or well
what do we do do we look at our unbox
our premiums do we dive into the news
um what do we do we're giving away the
premiums with questions
we can well yeah i mean well i figure
what we can do is we got plenty of [ __ ]
to give away with the questions
i figure with the like the we can unveil
the
premiums and then give those out like
after we've looked at them and [ __ ]
okay to just ever just to any [ __ ]
person i think so like whoever wants it
the most
and [ __ ] dude it's [ __ ] thunder dome
in here if you do that [ __ ]
who [ __ ] wants it
my wife's like be safe when you go out
there don't bring cove at home i'm like
i won't everybody [ __ ] fight
nerd cockfire um let's let's look at
those cause i've been waiting to
look at the let's do the bad batch
because is that still happening
is it still on the telly uh let me pull
this off yeah hold on
bad match oh banff ban is in everybody
that bad batch is on the bottom
of the pile did you literally bam finn
to [ __ ] state the obvious and [ __ ]
we knew that but we were asking you is
it still on it is still going and it's
uh
it's getting good it's getting real good
this is a bad batch star wars the bad
batch box uh you know they
i'm sure you've seen online unboxing
people they send out premiums and stuff
like that to
promote this is in promotion of uh the
bad batch which
jc is achingly familiar with started on
may 4th still going
still going it's uh 16 episodes i think
we're halfway through
all right this is from creative with
love let's see what's in it
as we open it up uh the premier watch
box is brought to you by created with
love our goal at created with love is
pretty simple
get people talking and interacting in
ways that are fun
and engaging each themed date night we
create includes unique games and
activities
that integrate techniques and strategies
to build stronger relationships
through laughter and quality time how
awesome that's really sweet so they put
together this old box right here
let's see what's in this box number one
destination space an intergalactic date
night
mission so it's a game like that you
play
and in order to want to have sex i'm
sure eventually it could lead to nudity
you know what's awesome
sex they're not giving that away in the
box mark it's [ __ ]
disney
so what it what do you want is there is
there
what is there a [ __ ] story behind
this so
uh we were talking in the green room
alley
and uh mark knew that we had the
skywalker ranch wines this is the only
place
outside of disney in southern california
you can get them is that right so
uh mark
why aren't we hyping that why didn't we
like start with that other than like
bring out
the wine i was doing a [ __ ] bit
and i did it and i got the wine and i
showed the bottle
and the force is with me [ __ ]
how does it taste like wine
it's better than like it's sand course
it gets all over
um all right also in the box oh very
appropriate
it's a drinking cup of some sort one of
those
thermal cups but it's the star wars logo
and of course
the opening words uh that have kept us
interested since 1977
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
which as a child confused the [ __ ] out
of me because i'm like
if this happened a long time ago why do
they have lasers and we don't my
father's like
shut up leave it alone yeah [ __ ] it it's
sci-fi
you idiot uh they also gave us
in here a bag of m m's so we'll be
giving that out
skittles are a bad batch it is a good
badge
excellent i mean it's not vegan so for
me it's a bad badge uh they got oh
the love game the nut hitter uh a bad
batch
set of socks look at that
yes ladies and gentlemen got a van of
that [ __ ]
this is join us for the launch of star
wars the bad batch
may the fourth we're a little late
presented by verizon
uh of course the david gore t-shirt
can't see it what is it i assume it must
say bad batch in some way
that tracks a bunch of
bad batch stickers a
jesus what i mean like
who has to be convinced to watch star
wars
with this much [ __ ] swag like please
man [ __ ] here you can [ __ ] my wife
just watch the bad batch
play this game with my wife and then you
can have sex with her god almighty man
like [ __ ] they're supposed to make
money not give it away
this is a wicked ass book man uh the
clone wars character encyclopedia
it's got everybody in it it's a 15
book 19 in canada suckers
uh this is jc is that a symbol
bad batch symbol of some sort it looks
like uh
like hunter or somebody says 99 on the
back that means oh yeah uh clone force
99 is the bad batch
which is the opposite of 66
which was the order to kill all the jedi
[ __ ] hey
dave filoni slipping in some uh some
subtle
he's slipping let me tell you something
you saying dave felony slipping it
made my [ __ ] dick move
it shows you how good he is at his job
and then finally uh
galactic berry crunch popcorn but it's
got like a bad batch sticker man so
and it's blue because everything in star
wars is blue is that right
the most appetizing blue milk spots good
blue
blue is just space all right
let's start giving this [ __ ] out who
wants uh
the here uh like we gotta do about
questions
let's do it in a fun way um
[ __ ] ask a bad batch question listen
dude if you're gonna give away every
item of a 400 item box
we're never gonna do the rest of the
show fair enough who wants this
there you go go i saw that hand come up
come up get it
show your [ __ ] face on camera don't
hide show him look at that camera
say i want free he's a winner give it up
ladies and gentlemen
who wants this wicked bad batch hat
hands up
i saw that hand go right up come on up
claim thy hat
look at that camera and say thank you
bad badge
good enough i feel like you need a swag
gun
so you could fire this [ __ ] into the
crowd this is my favorite [ __ ] part
of the show giving [ __ ] out
i feel like i feel like oprah i'm like
you get a book you get a book
uh the clone wars encyclopedia i saw
that hand go up come on up here
get up here you give it to her first
come up you gotta come on camera and say
i love
bad badge there you go take your book
you did it
welcome to hollywood this sounds so
wrong
that's what they want uh fan wraps uh
clone four stickers who wants them
i saw that hand go up right there's two
hands yeah you come on up now you're
like [ __ ] i gotta walk all the way up
there all the way up here for [ __ ]
stuff for [ __ ] stickers i should have
held off for a [ __ ] shirt
tell them good folks at bad match right
there in the camera thank you
thank you well done give it up everybody
you're making me feel dirty
kevin look at this [ __ ] bad bad
t-shirt before you put your hands up let
me tell you what size it is ladies and
gentlemen
this is a star wars as soon as i finish
saying the size jet your hand up
xl bam right there i just saw come on up
tell them you love the bad badge
very convincing directed by kevin smith
um oh kids pair of bad bat socks
i saw that hand go up come on up what
[Music]
you want the socks she's no she's
shaking her head no
she very much do you want to fight this
woman for the socks
come on up you tell that camera thank
you bad badge how about m
ms you like that all right whip the m
m's over to that mouthy person
proving that [ __ ] you know cheaters
win all the time
and uh we got a box of skittles kids
who's in the skittles
taste the rainbow [ __ ]
beautiful and then of course this is a
quality [ __ ] item
i saw those two hands jet up come on
come on
catch it and then because here we
believe in using every piece of the
[ __ ] turkey ladies and gentlemen who
wants the bad batch
box oh don't forget the sex game oh in
the sex game you come in tell the camera
i [ __ ] love you bad badge
yes and then of course destination
destination ass is the name of the game
you in the back that that hand you're
into it
yeah why not that's a good come on up
come get your game winner
with love it says you gotta have two
players jump on camera and say
you people really win on j um fat man
beyond
that well done very good uh this [ __ ]
box is killer man you can put [ __ ] in it
i don't think i have to sell a box to
you particularly a free one but it's got
a cool picture on it who wants to walk
home
with a bad bang it's all you man come on
[Music]
i believe that outstanding um all right
we've got
uh that's some prizes for later man but
how about we do this other premium thing
yeah so this came from loki
oh yeah that's right at first i heard
somebody going oh man another one but
then i said loki's like oh i'll suck
loki dick right away
that's right we got a wonderful set of
packages also from the good folks at
disney that sent that this is from the
folks
that do the marvel side loki on top is a
tva
folder with a note inside that says dear
new recruit this is what it looks like
for those at home dear a new recruit
on behalf of everyone at the time
variance authority we'd like to say
welcome
uh we were created by the timekeepers to
protect the sacred timeline
we're excited to present you with your
new recruit package
filled with everything you'll need to be
an incredible worker on your first day
on the job we're thrilled for you to
help protect the timeline good
uh from variants such as loki
uh why would they put that right in the
[ __ ] thing plus his name's at the
bottom
uh one of them i was believing it up
until then good luck and remember time
passes differently at the tva
for more information uh start streaming
marvel studios loki and original series
on disney plus
for all time always uh the good folks at
marvel studios
who wants the folder
done and done man come on over here i
love paper
yes you say thank you marvel
thank you look at that that's
appreciation man
give it up for them that's gratitude
stationary products all right let's see
what they gave us there's a tva box you
open up the tva box looks like this on
the back
got a very cool logo so remember kids
somebody gonna leave here with this very
useful box
my mother raised me to do [ __ ] oh look
at this
this is a [ __ ] take it out that's why
i said to mark in the back alley take it
out
this is a [ __ ] quality oh we broke it
already [ __ ]
it's a miss minutes clock it is a miss
minutes clock
that is so cool isn't it man a uh 13 and
a half inch
cordless wood wall clock go ahead
tick tuck tick
tock [ __ ] yeah instruction
manual comes with it
uh look at that man so you take the
plastic thing off and it's the you know
the clock lady
it's uh what's her name he's looking at
tara strong it's a [ __ ] lady what's her
name miss minutes
miss minutes that's right to walk away
that's right it's the voice of tara
strong
um all right miss minutes clock you got
i can't just put your hands up you gotta
[ __ ]
let's give maybe we get now
maybe
i can't argue with that you want this
clock so badly you stood up
come get it man she won the clock ladies
and gentlemen
[Music]
you look right in that camera and you
say [ __ ] fat man beyond give [ __ ] out
thank you well done i'll take that that
was like
like a jason muse level performance it's
okay
uh do you want the instructions for it
do you want the box i should probably
give you the box give it a whole box
no worries there it is do you want the
wrapping as well just in case
you're covered all right man look she
won a clock this is what happens when
you come to fat man beyond
you learn to tell time yes
thank you thank you i'm i'm full service
it's a man who worked at a mall at some
point
that's true i used to work at a
convenience store i don't know if you
know that
a big old box says logie on the front
has a handle so later on somebody's
going to get a really nice
handled [ __ ] box it's like a suitcase
it's got a tv it has
a 51 you can pack your [ __ ] and go back
to wherever the [ __ ] you came from
there's the tva logo on the back
let's see what's inside ladies and
gentlemen
first up of course david gore loki pin
hands in the air who wants it
i saw that wait why you already got
something but you didn't
come get it man come get your pin you
don't want the pin
see now i like doing this way because
they don't know
what could be in the box excellent point
excellent tell these good folks on
camera
[ __ ] fat man beyond gave me this
goddamn free pin
[Applause]
all right let's see what else we got
there was this [ __ ] too though that's
true that's true
sure there's some paper um all right
this is wrapped up all night so you'll
get the [ __ ] bubble wrap too just
don't
be bubble wrap popping during the show
jc will throw your ass out
here we go it's a as expected a tva
time variance authority mug you can put
[ __ ] soup in this
um it's it's pretty damn you could put
wine in it
you get super mad of a fight with your
boyfriend and or girlfriend
smash it in the ground and they'd be
like you won that and they're like
that's how [ __ ] mad i am
and [ __ ] it could be an instrument of
results
yes who that hand went up awfully quick
come tell them i'm drinking [ __ ] because
of fat man
that was awesome you're smart you're
smart to thank that guy
um okay this is a classy ass [ __ ] box
you want to talk about nice boxes
this alone who gives a [ __ ] what's in it
it's a nice wood box it's got the time
variance authority stamped into it again
who the [ __ ] wasn't watching this show
like who do they need to convince with
all this disney save your money we're in
inside a pen very classy very classy
wooden pen
i didn't even say anything yet i'm just
i'm saying she's declaring her intent
i saw two hands go up there so two hands
go up there it is a classy ass [ __ ]
pen
and listen to this wooden box listen
that sounds like pine i think that's
pine let's uh come up with a question
somebody who uh you got to answer the
question uh to win this and the question
is
should be a loki question um
who is the first person we ever saw
and i'm not talking in the timeline but
we ever saw in a movie
loki kill
whoever can answer it can answer it
we got to give this away though man we
will to whoever answers it
this week on boxes with kevin and mark
yes fat man boxes
nobody [ __ ] remembers do you know
agent carlson that's not correct
miscellaneous shield agent i think i
might buy that
i mean he didn't kill any asgardian and
thor
this is too hard i know
let's just go back to first 10 and the
air wins
you win come on up and get it man come
get your pen
trust me there's more [ __ ] uh
you take this uh pen you look in that
camera and you say
uh i'm gonna write my ass off because of
marvel
it's a time variance authority jacket
the same
the same kind that was given to loki
although on the back
it does not say variant it says tva
you know what first first we give it up
for the good folks at uh
loki for sending this uh fat package but
[Applause]
um i saw a young man on his feet
and without that young man we don't get
the killer art that we have week after
week give it up
for the dark nick gonzalez
look into that camera and tell him who
you are
[Applause]
all right kids more socks we got another
pair of socks says tva
time variants authority on it [ __ ]
sucks marvel socks man you wear these
you step into success
who wants a marvel socks count of three
one two three hands up
bam you get the socks come get the socks
tell them i [ __ ] won these socks i'm
fat man beyond right there
[Music]
[ __ ] a that's a performance
who wants a tesseract that is [ __ ]
dope man it's a a tesseract
memo cube man that's [ __ ] that is
really clever you can write note after
note
sticky notes they're post-it notes and
it looks like the tesseract
[Applause]
i'm gonna let you i'm gonna i'm gonna
count to three and on three
mark give it to
a teacher come on up teach your wins
[Applause]
[Music]
you look in that camera you say teach
your children well
well done hot for teacher
ladies and gentlemen a stapler a legit
time variance authority stapler man
start building your desk set right now
you want it you're all the way in the
back
i'm not [ __ ] throwing it to you have
you not been paying attention
are you coming up for it
oh my god she's like i want it go get it
she's coming up for give it up for her
ladies and gentlemen
she fought the demon gravity
that stabilizer you look at that camera
right now and you say i'm so [ __ ]
glad i won a stapler
[Applause]
continuing the desk set theme dispenser
from the tva
ladies and gentlemen you have a never
have so many people wanted
a tape dispenser in their lives granted
we're all digital in this world but if
you want to go analog
a tva tape dispenser on the count of
three
mark looking uh looking for hands you
tell me who goes up first i'm closing my
eyes
can't do this anymore it's too much of a
sophie's choice here we go
one two three pick
over here that dude you won come get
your tape dispenser
was there not a bunch of people vying
for it uh
i wanted to give some love to the left
wing smart smart
bamf oh banff man is here i've seen some
nerdy [ __ ] in this bar
but people screaming their heads off
over a stapler and a tape dispenser
might be that to take the cake
it's just postcode but everyone's like
i'll [ __ ] take it
you take this tape dispenser you look at
that camera and you say i'm gonna
[ __ ] tape [ __ ] together because of
fat man beyond
well done give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen
last but not least we got a uh a little
notepad here
uh that says everything you've ever said
as printed out by the tva very [ __ ]
clever very clever
uh i'll let uh banff man pick this bam
man i'm gonna count to three
you pick the hand uh do all sides of the
room
here we go one two three do it batman
i think it was this guy you were early
this is captain america here captain
america wins captain america always wins
[Applause]
you look in that camera and you say
marvel gave me a [ __ ] pad a mini pad
mini pad um all right kids now
the best part the hobo suitcase it's the
box
you could go home you could put liquor
in this
money [ __ ] weed this is a great weed
box
says loki on it be mischievous and stuff
got a handle
here we go count of three says time
variance authority on the back
jc me
you see whose hand goes up okay count
three one two three who wants a box
one guy right here one guy gets a box
[Applause]
you look in the camera and you say
[ __ ] i love boxing
[ __ ] all that free [ __ ] goes good
with that skywalker one it really does
um all right full of member berries yes
banff man is here
if uh what mark's drinking looks good
you can uh go order a glass from your
bartender
or if you're feeling particularly
bernardine tonight
you can you can buy a bottle of the
pinot noir
where you can only get it here
only here do you want to tell them how
much a bottle costs are you like
absolutely
bottle bottles 130 of pinot noir
just like the [ __ ] movie itself
kickstarter money
yes expensive one uh that is and this is
the only place you can get it
uh this in some place down in anaheim
somewhere
ticket price is a little more expensive
too far
should we should we talk about loki we
might as well man
being that we just opened the loki box
who wants to talk about the latest
episode of loki ladies and gentlemen uh
we watched the loki because we knew you
watched loki and we wanted to be as cool
and hip as you so let's talk about loki
episode two thoughts um i i am now on
board
i was a little tentative on the first
episode because you know i'm that guy um
but what i realized and it got me on
board is that
for these first two episodes loki is the
remake of demolition man that i didn't
know i wanted
oh oh really
really because demolition man if you
remember
uh wesley snipes is simon stallone uh
stallone is frozen in jail yeah he gets
cryo frozen
and and thought out to chase down wesley
snipes to simon phoenix
and so the police of the future turned
to the guy from the past to hunt down
the criminal from his own time so loki
we have
the tva looking to catch a loki and so
who do they turn to
they turn to a loki and so far the first
two episodes are very like
cop procedural right down to like we're
sitting down [ __ ] zodiac style
looking at files and [ __ ]
you know like do you did you do research
yeah i did my research do you have a
black captain yeah i got a black captain
are we going onto the field yeah we're
going onto the field yeah like do you
get a jacket
totally get a jacket yeah it's kind of a
cop show
and i'm not mad about it um because the
writing is is
really really strong like it's really
sharp and it's [ __ ] owen wilson and
tom hiddleston having a blast
but once i figured out that it was just
demolition man i was like all right
i see you marvel i'm here for it
i don't know where it's going nobody
knows where it's [ __ ] going but
for now i'm here for it um what did you
think of the first appearance of uh
well for now we'll we'll call her lady
loki
and not potentially the enchantress i
mean yes
sport potential spoilers yes um
i mean we did sort of call it i think
the last time we talked about it
right the fact that that they did sort
of tip the hand to when you looked at
loki's file in the handy manila envelope
that that gentleman
walked away with um his sex was marked
as fluid
and so the idea that you might get a a
pan-gendered loki um was kind of on the
table and so yeah i'm i'm here for
because i didn't need to see him chasing
himself around
but to see him chase somebody who's
potentially sharper and
better and savvier than he is that's
kind of what i want
and if the long game of this show which
is giving us a loki back in the mcu
prime
who's kind of exactly the way the loki
that we lost in infinity war was
that feels like it's a quest worth
taking yeah i'll take that journey yeah
like even if we wind up oh this is just
where we [ __ ] started with the guy
i'm like good
he's i like him he's good to have around
he's good and they got to have their
cake and eat it too they killed them off
very dramatically and [ __ ]
and yet we still get to play with them
um yeah it's been a continued good time
my uh my wife has not uh gone as deep
into this as juan division and uh boy
you having trouble there
there you go look at that the force
awakens
poor man ooh middle chlorine in the
chlorine in the chlorines
is it tasty it's pretty tasty you want
something i'm not really a wine person
yes
rose is the fruit punch of wines and is
it really
it really is it's got like a bunch of
sugar in it and because
i'm fasting i'm like right now what time
is it
it is 9 10. some 50 hours into a fast i
don't want to break it with [ __ ] star
wars wine
star wars snow cone yes so where's wine
now
um yeah jennifer was just like i don't
like it as much as i like the other ones
and i was like really cause like why not
like he's pretty charming and
she's like i don't know it just doesn't
grab me the same way but i'm still
in way deep in um how many episodes
uh six that's it that's it so
as of next week we're halfway through
and it wraps up just in time for black
widow
is that when is it air when is it
wednesdays tonight they put it up at
what midnight like 1201.
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] we could leave here and
[ __ ] yeah
or we can stay here and watch it
together
[Applause]
so for the for the first show back we
slept over
um coming home i'm not sure i think i
live at the barn now
um what uh did you see suicide squad
trailer i did see the suicide squad
trailer um what do you think
uh i am still on board for the suicide
squad yeah they haven't lost me i'm
still weigh in
my favorite moment hands down was uh
harley quinn going sorry i'm late i had
to go number two
and there's just something real simple
and clean about like somebody impossibly
pretty saying they just took a [ __ ]
my kind of comedy um loved
seeing uh the eye of i i think we don't
it's no longer spoilers but the eye of
starrow
uh loves seeing king shark get whipped
around by star i am [ __ ] so there
for starro uh but the whole thing looks
fantastic man
they uh they really don't have to put
out another trailer but they're gonna i
was gonna go
yeah like they don't have to do much
more
i'm weighing she doesn't get a lot of
credit man margot like
everyone always talks about ben and
henry but it's like she's now played
a character in the dc cinematic universe
dc extended universe
more times than most of them right
how many times did ben play batman
played
bbs and justice league in justice league
yeah
and then he pops up for the suicide
squad how many times has margot played
harley quinn now suicide squad the other
suicide squad birds of prey
and birds of prayer her own flick and
how many times did
henry cavill play superman uh man of
steel bvs
and justice league so she's about tie
with him right now
um yeah man she's single-handedly
keeping the dc
extended universe alive although [ __ ]
you saw the pictures from flash this
week
michael keaton with [ __ ] gray hair
looking exactly like he [ __ ] should
and i know a lot of people online it
shows you a real generational difference
man where a bunch of people were like
[ __ ] some old man batman was he gonna
do [ __ ] safe pudding
and [ __ ] like that and i get it but i'm
like
kids that's our batman and you know
that's i see there's a lot of
online separation between the people who
are like holy [ __ ]
keaton's back as batman and a bunch of
people were like why
[ __ ] move forward they'd much prefer
ben's batman or something like that
and there's a rumor that like that
version of batman is
gonna continue coming into our one
universe at the end of this i don't know
if they're continuing
a multiverse or whatnot but it's the
indicator is it's not the only
um uh michael keaton batman appearance
instead
yes it sounds like they're setting up
batman beyond although it feels like
they're gonna do it with batgirl instead
of batman
if i had to [ __ ] guess but i i
thought the whole internet would be like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he's got gray hair
cause he's normally bald this is [ __ ]
amazing
he's got that toupee and it shows you
man that like it's
it's so we could just we just find
reasons to divide from one another even
though we [ __ ] all
we all love batman but they're like ew
you like
old batman i like young viral batman i'm
like my batman still [ __ ] i think
but i loved seeing that [ __ ] picture
man i mean i know
it would have been cooler to see him in
a trailer first but
just seeing that head of hair i was like
that's exactly
what [ __ ] tim burton's bruce wayne
would look like now
oh i can't [ __ ] wait and then uh we
saw the first supergirl
shot which as per usual of course is
never as impressive because they always
show
somebody hung from two [ __ ] wires
without the full costume on and [ __ ] but
you got your first peek out it looks
[ __ ] great kid looked great she's got
short hair
um but i saw one shot of her in a crowd
wearing the [ __ ] cape as well
i saw some people online bitching about
that going there's too many [ __ ]
people in this i'm like oh my god
put every [ __ ] character in it man
like everyone like [ __ ] that's this
is their chance 40 characters in endgame
yeah i'll take them all [ __ ] put them
all in it's a time travel piece man
so i i can't [ __ ] wait that all that
[ __ ] looks wonderful to me
speaking of superheroes yeah i went to
the movies this past week
oh [ __ ] and i saw
a little picture that i like to call
because it's the title
fast nine ah
is it how is it out already not yet it's
on friday
and kevin kevin
[Applause]
kevin yeah is this the skywalker talking
it's it's the best
movie i saw that day
because kevin yes
they drive a car i hear they do that a
lot
into outer space
into into outer space
is where this car that gets driven
by people with a steering wheel
that works in space in space
all i'm going to say no spoilers
it's [ __ ] nuts is it
uh it's so weird because like i'm
sitting here quietly judging it
you know going like god damn it this
sounds so but
if you were like an iron man did it i'd
be like get the [ __ ] out of here
oh my god there's geniuses at marvel
um yeah it's just i've not seen any of
the fast movies so i can't
i'm gonna get a chubby going for it man
but uh if i
driving in space is the closest i've
ever been to like oh
that's something yeah um yeah
listen if you like these movies you will
be uh
wildly entertained by this one this is
supposed to come out a year ago right
yeah none of it makes sense right but
none of them make sense save the first
one when it was just like they're
stealing stereos
and like and i'm a cop so i got to stop
them that's like
that's the plot that's how it began
that's how it began now they're driving
in space
i like to call that character evolution
truly
it's growth that's development right
there it really is um
but yeah along the way it's it's it's
not about the destination
kevin his journey it's about the friends
you make along the way
oh
so quite like [ __ ] my little pony the
whole thing is friendship is magic
ship is magic paranoid and literal magic
because they're superheroes now who
cannot die
and they drive in space and they drive
in [ __ ] space man how did you was it
a
preview was it was it packed um
no they've been very good so far about
press screenings to keep
to keep [ __ ] kind of still like we're
only doing 66 percent and we're saving
every other seat
vacant but it was uh it was it was well
populated
and i think everybody had a good time
okay because that's what those movies
are for
they're not for plot they're not for i
don't know
complicated narrative they're not for
physics or logic um
they're just like so that at some point
when you drive a car into space you're
like that checks out
did you eat snacks in the movie yeah
were you masculists and [ __ ] uh i was
masters in my seat
really once you got to the sea you were
just like well i had to eat a bavarian
legend pretzel
no and have you guys had a bavarian
legend
have you uh had it had it come out
because it's rough that's a lot of
[ __ ] pretzel man that's a pound and a
half of pretzel
where where the amc if they got a
big-ass pretzel
bavarian legend the shit's as big as
your head you never [ __ ] realized it
would have to come out of your eggs
i couldn't expect it to come out whole
in a fun shape
let's go to space that's you thinking
about a fast nine long after the movie
was over
pretty much i wish this was faster
hashtag familia
um i have not gone out to the movies yet
uh
soon i know i didn't get to go i was
gonna go see uh quiet place too
um because i wanted to see if it got
loud
and uh i haven't gotten a chance to
run out to see that just yet almost had
the wife ready to go
almost and then she was just like let's
watch this instead have you watched
physical
on apple tv with rose byrne nope it's
[ __ ] good
they put up three episodes on friday i
like it i like it very much
you know what else i saw that i went to
the movies for what in the heights
you saw in a theater i did because
they're giving away that [ __ ] on hbo max
you know i know but see the thing is
that i didn't want people to be able to
see me crying
when i was watching it you wanted to go
away from family
like i needed my hashtag family to be
like in the dark with me
so they couldn't see like just every
other [ __ ] song just
oh so my god have you seen the show
i saw the show at uh a csun performance
by college students and like a rep
show right because i'm like i'm a lint
fan i saw hamilton i want to see
everything and this was the one other
thing i could see
and it was great it was great with
[ __ ] college kids doing it
and so to go and see it in in a movie
theater
with legit professionals and treated
with the same
love and care and affection as every
other major motion picture pictures
treated
and with a cast that looks like that and
with that much energy and buoyancy and
emotional swing
it was glorious like it was one of my
favorite times in a theater
uh in the last couple of years not just
the last year because that's a guy
yeah that's the best movie i saw that
day um
and not that scale but i loved it we
balling
like a baby what is the connection do
you or is it
did you is that the neighborhood no no i
grew up in the bronx yeah which is
so what is this parallel it's washington
heights is the northern northwestern tip
of manhattan
um but it's it's the the cultural
specificity of that neighborhood
you know and it's a neighborhood and
it's a culture that that is rarely shown
on screen
and if it is it's never shown on screen
with that kind of reverence and that
kind of understanding
you know there there is some controversy
about it because there's
the the casting of that movie is
supposed to be a neighborhood that's
very dominican
and the dominican republic is a very
afro-cuban nation and so but the casting
of the movie was very
light in in that regard which is fair
it's 100 fair but you know like
it's still really good and it's still
progress and all progress
is good you know we we have to be able
to like a thing while still holding it
to to accountability and so you could
have done better but what you did was
still pretty great
and so just that feeling that you know
and i've had it in movies like moonlight
and i've had it in movies
about other underrepresented communities
of people finally getting to be seen
in a real way and that just moves me you
know and to watch it with such care and
with such
love it's like oh i see how you would
feel like you feel how i felt watching
black panther and so if you get to feel
that way then i feel that way for you
right and so there was there was just
this wonderful like [ __ ] buoyancy
in my in my heart walking out of that
movie and so i highly recommend it and
it's also if you got hbo max it's also
free you ain't got to leave the house
what do you mean it's on hbo oh you
could watch it yeah but you you were
like
i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna drop some
bills i'm gonna go support
you supporters i voted with wallet i'm
gonna spend some of this white boy money
and i rented out
a theater for myself
[Applause]
it makes me go like do i even have white
boy money
because i've not done that yeah
you rented out the whole theater for now
how much is it it's 300 bills
it's not bad that's not bad i mean i
know that sounds crazy a little bit
because that's like
it's insane but it's also yeah for a
party if you were like
in lieu of like everybody come over my
house and we'll throw a party it's like
everybody go to the movie theater and
leave your [ __ ] there
yeah much better party i highly
recommend it if you have the means
it's the only way to fly [ __ ] one
percenter over here
all right none of it was kickstarter
money i promise yes
no wonder madly [ __ ] renting theaters
and [ __ ]
bring me another bavarian legend
[Laughter]
knowing that you got to [ __ ] it out
you're like i don't care
um shall we dive into the news let's do
something ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
it's finally time to look at the [ __ ]
things that are happening mr mark
bernardin here long before
he was uh doing what he does now he was
doing another thing where he covered the
[ __ ] news so he's got a nose
for news and he nosed out some news and
we're gonna do that news right now give
it up for mark bernard and he's got the
news
this is this is the first time i printed
out the news
in like 14 months a long time right i
almost forgot
today and that would have been weird i
would have been on youtube could you
have been
you got some news
some [ __ ] stranger things [ __ ] jc do
we have a
sharpie or something like that a lot of
folks left things but
no writing utensils i'll take that thank
you
does everyone mine like one color black
and [ __ ]
well nate's got a whole [ __ ] pouch
full of pens
well i mean you know [ __ ] what are
they gonna all last nate like i'll take
purple we don't want like a reservoir
dogs thing going on here you know what
everyone's getting black
she's got that we're good
this is from kevin are you here where
are you
[ __ ] right there thank you man i wear
the other one
i almost wore it tonight i was going to
be like i'll wear it tonight and then i
was like you know what i got to wear the
jacket um this is [ __ ] dope thank you
people hand me [ __ ] all the time and
whatnot and like particularly clothing
is generally like wear this shirt
because it's their thing and stuff
kevin gave me this like [ __ ] hoodie
that like i legit wear every [ __ ] day
and my wife's like where'd you get that
i was like kevin conroy and she's like
batman
and i was like the other kevin conroy
and she was like if i met him i was like
you've seen him and stuff man but he
brought me this [ __ ] shirt and like
i never [ __ ] wear things that people
give me but i [ __ ] love it
and she this was her instant reaction
because it's very typically jennifer
she's like why don't you just [ __ ]
marry kevin conroy
i walk down the room she saw had joy in
a garment she didn't buy and it made her
mad
that's [ __ ] marriage ladies and
gentlemen thank you for this
can't [ __ ] wait to wear that um all
right all right news
news it up um stranger things is is
coming to an end
is that right how many seasons has it
been now i got a reason to finally watch
it
it's been three seasons the fourth
season is coming out soonish
um and like not to break anybody's balls
but it was always going to end
um i know it's not generally different
brothers i'm sure
like we'd like to do something else yeah
this is great they've been doing it for
it feels like 10 years
but david harbor doing the thing that
actors do when they're promoting another
movie
just let some [ __ ] drop about it um and
he said that you know he's out there
promoting black widow he's out there
promoting black widow you're gonna run a
theater for that or no
money bags [ __ ] scrooge mcduck diving
in your [ __ ]
solid gold it's going harder to do
because people are going back to the
movies like they would
amc would happily rent you a house when
nobody was going into the theater
now the people are back they're like
[ __ ] you can't have this i would
imagine now the price is going to go up
right yeah and i'm not money bags money
bags
no you're not you don't got that robert
kirkman money i don't got that
that's scrooge mckirkman money he's
diving in piles of gold and [ __ ]
um but yes the the duffer brothers have
already said that the fourth season
won't be the end of the road
but according to harbor they're getting
closer than they've ever been to
wrapping up the show
right um well good for i mean what a
success they've had with that
everybody loves that pop cultural
phenomenon
it'll rain forever and ever and blah
blah
and then harbor whose character um
hopper hopper sorry it's a wine talking
um we thought he died at the end of
season three
spoiler again if you haven't seen season
three i'm sorry but hopper bites the
dust only to see him again in some
russian prison somewhere
but according to harbor they were always
interested in the idea of the gandalf
resurrection
gan off the grey who fights the balrog
and then becomes gandalf the white lord
of the rings i know
um thank you
yeah thank you for mark explaining that
[Music]
uh but it's the idea that the character
has to to be resurrected and
mythologically hopper in a sense had to
change
so uh so apparently he's going to be
wearing lots of white robes
and maybe he's coming back i like him
he's
he seems like a genuine dude i
interviewed him once or twice for
sundance [ __ ] for the imdb and he was
he seemed like the real deal and super
appreciative to be there
and happy i i like him and i like him
and he was great on snl when he was the
host
i judge most people who [ __ ] i don't see
is it who gave me this or am i signing
it
i just keep this thank you
what's your name matt everyone be more
like
[ __ ] matt right if everyone brought a
joint i'm going home with 75 [ __ ]
joints that'll carry me for two days so
thank you
thank you that was very cool
[ __ ] no
didn't you learn anything from the
pandemic no more sharing
uh thank you for that they want you to
sign i signed it oh well done so i'll
put it over here
all right what other news um what news
mark what hoe
uh sigrunny weaver was almost in
watchmen
i [ __ ] heard this right yeah i mean
why would you pass
up but yeah gene smart who was doing
press for
for hacks which i've now seen two
episodes of and i love hacks is
fantastic
let me tell you something right now gene
smart for some reason is like leave your
wife
be with me like that yeah and i think my
wife would be like go
and not because she's like i hate you
but because she's like jean smart what a
score she'd probably
push me out of the way and try to join
her instead she is
[ __ ] phenomenal on hacks she was
absolutely phenomenal
in watchmen the part that she got yeah
because because we even turned it down
not crazy so
so damon wrote it for sigourney weaver
yeah which makes sense because he's the
guy that you know [ __ ] prometheus and
[ __ ] he loves them alien movies
and also and sigourney weaver but like
she passes
and then they go to gene smart with two
days before production
that's what happened that's what
happened well [ __ ] good because she
was
she was for me like one of the brightest
spots in a brilliant show
she's so [ __ ] wonderful yeah i mean
she said her quote is they hired me two
days before i started
uh i had segrene weaver to thank for
turning down the roles so thank you
sigrini she knew nothing about the
graphic novel i started reading the
pilot and i said oh god this is amazing
i'd never really done science fiction
and the fact that damon was able to use
that tragic part of our story
that almost nobody knew about that was
so shocking that she'd never heard of
the tulsa massacre
that's why i went that's why i think he
said no when i asked him to do a second
season
because he put everything into the first
i believe that although i've heard
rumors
didn't you hear something a couple of i
don't know like a month ago they were
like there
may not be it for watchmen yeah i mean i
think that that
hbo would gladly have more watchmen yeah
damon was like i think i'm done right
and so the question is and damon also
always said
if somebody else has a great idea for
watchmen i would gladly watch that show
um um but he's not jumping in right now
he he claims to not
want um to go back into that particular
gauntlet
because he's like i told my story i
don't have another story to tell
i respect the [ __ ] out of that indeed uh
i'm going to
score 86 [ __ ] jay and silent bob
movies
i'm like yeah that's a good idea um
you're
going for another [ __ ] can't you just
can't you do it with your mind obi-wan
i'm walking on sunshine baby i don't
think that was from that movie
that's what you think bam oh
bathman's in ladies gentlemen drink if
you got him
just because mark is uh enjoying the
bottle so much
alex vidal in youtube chat said uh
you should have a few of those before
your snyder cut review
and then glenn the geek hippie said it
would take more than a couple bottles to
get him to be able to have anything good
to say
i'm gonna get me one of those like the
beer helmets
and just put a bottle in each one and
just
double fist that [ __ ] a little i gotta
be honest with you like
the ba it's called skywalker so you're
like oh it must have a [ __ ]
picture of one of the skywalkers and
it's just some angel holding the [ __ ]
spear
because it's it's not disney owned
george owns it yeah but but disney how
about us
like luke skywalker knockoff and [ __ ]
buck rogers something like that
random angel person
sorry wait wait a second
i'm still mad about that prequels kevin
george has to play by the rules the same
way we have to play by the rules
you're getting away with a bigger star
wars reference than he is on his wine
uh all right so up next uh amc has
announced that before we get to see the
final season of the walking dead
um there will be a series called uh the
walking dead origins
which will cover the origin stories of
four fan favorite characters
uh i'm sure you can probably guess daryl
carol maggie and negan
so wait what is this now it's it's an
anthology show walking dead origins
where you'll get four episodes each one
focusing on
one of those characters so they're like
we're done psych yeah
well it's leading up to the final season
so it's one of those hey
we get to get everybody paid a little
bit oh so this isn't
after the show's over this is in
addition to the ending of the show this
is the prequel to the final season
which will then spin into the carol
darrell show which i expect to be a
variety show with songs and dances
um good for them boy they're [ __ ]
it's it's a it's that franchise is as
undead as the [ __ ]
monsters in the show itself that just
keeps going absolutely god bless makes
robert kirkman so much richer
he'll be the first to tell you though
he's like i don't make any of the money
from the he makes
money but he's like the real money comes
from the comic books which i find very
like inspiring because you would assume
like oh [ __ ] tv money must be richard
and roosevelt but they've been suing
amc since like season two so
i don't think anyone's getting rich off
of that but he's getting rich off his
[ __ ] comic books which is a testimony
to like
publish [ __ ] like don't let it
die and he's [ __ ] keeping it alive
with scott ben i
i like him so much not just his money i
like that
the money is nice yeah i remember doing
the math one month
when i saw the comic book sales charts
and like
this was still in the walking dead was
monthly so you know whatever it was like
walking dead
78 or whatever the hell it was we're
still selling between you know
30 and 40 40 and 50 000 issues a month
and then you still have the older issues
also on the charts and there's
always training but even floppies we're
still on the charts
and then the trades and there are at
this point like 15 or 16 trades
and five or six omnibuses and he keeps
most of that money
yeah like image takes their little bit
off the top and he splits his share with
his his
collaborators did you do the math did
you put it all together and come up with
a figure
like his monthly [ __ ] income is it
was 12
billion no but it was it was it was more
than 10 million dollars
in a month yeah i've
wasted my life i mean i'm sure he will
call like no it's not that
but like it's kind of that wow
i'm always kidding when i'm like he's a
richest guy he is the richest man i know
from comics no less yeah it's it's up
there with like
i remember reading about lin-manuel
miranda's not to make this the
insanity show but his cut of the
hamilton ticket sales and then the
soundtrack sales
and he was clearing something like you
know seven eight hundred thousand
dollars a week
wow as long as that show runs and the
more
touring companies they added the more
money he makes as the dude who wrote the
[ __ ] book
of the show and the lyrics and the music
and every soundtrack that sells
he gets a big cut of and like that
show's never not going to be on stage
somewhere so true
and so like if you do that one thing
that people like
and that keeps selling then yeah [ __ ]
kirkman money of course clerk's never
sold that [ __ ] well
people been asking me for years but hey
man can i do that as a musical i'm like
nah
now i'm like i should have said yeah
[ __ ]
all right what else we got um
wednesday is now officially disney plus
tv day what is wednesday wednesday
wednesday from now on all their shows
are going to drop
every disney plus show is going to
premiere on a wednesday
um i'm sorry i didn't you sound hurt
i think it's primarily because the world
is opening back up again i think during
the pandemic during the quarantine
during the lockdowns they knew we were
home
right and so we can do fridays oh that
makes sense and now that everybody's out
and about again like you know what maybe
wednesdays are better than people like
i'm going out to get [ __ ] blown and
or
blow on friday not watching [ __ ] loki
that's for wednesday wednesday's my wine
and loki night
god could you imagine people people were
give when was wanda vision
friday [ __ ] when the soldier was
friday and people were so
[ __ ] happy to have it they were like
oh that's my week man i put
the kids to bed and i [ __ ] watched my
wanda vision and i got my stories
and now they're like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm
gonna go out i'm gonna get
railed in a bar then maybe then i'll
give a [ __ ] about marvel
but wednesday makes sense makes sense
i'm in i'm happy it's wednesday look
my life you know back in 1994 became one
eternal friday so it doesn't matter what
[ __ ] day they put it on
i'm gonna watch it uh and the last new
story
and and i feel for people who love this
show but manifest
anybody manifest fan a manifesty what
are your fans called
manifestation mani pedis manny petty
uh manifest was cancelled by nbc that's
cause only that person liked it yeah
apparently
yeah you should have been louder nbc and
nobody watched it
uh they had a minute how many seasons
they had three seasons what the [ __ ] man
like you know
you can't [ __ ] three [ __ ] seasons
and the thing that was
irking people was that it was why the
day it got canceled it was also the
number one show on netflix
and i hear netflix had a chance to
rescue it netflix is like we're good
yeah netflix netflix decided ultimately
that they were passing
on extending manifest and they said
there's no other way to take it out
because it's very byzantine the [ __ ]
rights and stuff like there was a slim
window to do it with netflix other than
that no
yeah i mean it would have followed the
the lucifer path right
we got cancelled on fox warner brothers
owns the show they can then shop it
elsewhere
the couple seasons that had already been
airing on netflix had done pretty well
for them so netflix rolled the dice
and the actors were still under contract
and the costs weren't that high
and they could make that happen but i
think that the the interim between
cancellation and any potential netflix
pickup
was too long to be able to guarantee the
cast could come back and the sets might
have been struck and then it becomes a
whole new show
and that's more money than i think they
were willing to spend um well our hearts
go out to all the folks that loved
manna-fest but like you live through the
pandemic
[ __ ] you that's what you get um that's a
shame
i wish everybody's favorite show could
go on forever
mark i'd still be watching davey and
goliath
i'm learning sooner or later church
lessons yeah they'd still be teaching me
my morals uh but sooner or later all
good things come to a [ __ ] end
unless you're jay and sal and bob that's
going to go right till i die
right uh what else we got that's it for
the next are you [ __ ] me yeah man
the news i'm done oh banff man is in
ladies i have two things
to bring up that the chat's been talking
about all night the first
is yeah hold on before you dive into
that since you [ __ ]
interrupted what is it like our whole
life for the last
like year has been like what's going on
in chat
and now that we've got real friends in
the real world
like we've stopped thinking about it but
what is going on in chat has have they
been
people are excited they're excited to
hear uh the crowd cheering
[Applause]
they're they're excited that you guys
are back behind the bar and there's not
a piece of plexiglass between you
yes that's right no more sneeze guard
come on through somebody got a bottle
someone bought some skywalker give it up
skywalker
may the force be with you but a young
[ __ ] uh
young grape farmer uh in northern
california who needs your financial help
ladies and gentlemen
poor man by the name of farmer lucas
there are so many member berries that he
can squeeze to make
his juicy juicy wine he has but one
dream well he had many dreams this is
just another one of them
there's a lot of talk about um
about carissa everybody
everybody at home um a lot of people
talk
your comic book that came out if you
want to
plug that tell uh
for the folks at home to tell them about
adora yeah
a door in the distance is a book that
i've been working on for
on and off about 15 years um inspired by
um i guess the moment that we got a
diagnosis for my daughter
on the autism spectrum and i the thing
that i did not want to do was i didn't
want to write about what it's like to
raise a kid on the spectrum
because those books are everywhere and
and more to the point
i am the least interesting person in
this story you know the question that i
always had was
what are the things that she's thinking
about when she can't tell me why is she
laughing
and i don't know why she's laughing why
does she cry and i don't know what's
hurting her
and so what's happening inside her mind
that's prompting these these emotions
because she doesn't have access to them
not in a way that you can tell me and so
because i'm a nerd that manifested as
like this quest story
about this girl and this sort of you
know andalusian
you know port city who gets the call of
destiny which is you have to go and
question to the unknown
and and confront a force called a
distance which threatens to destroy
everything
and so i've been working on this book
for a long time
i kind of wrote it wrote it wrote it
about five years ago
and had speak spoken to publishers about
it for a long time and lots of them like
dug the idea but
there was always some barrier for for
them hopping on and saying like well
could you change this how could you
tweak that
and because this was this was the one
that meant the most to me i was like no
i respect that understand that
but that's not the way i want to do this
got to be the way you want it you know
like
it's personal it's personal like i'm i'm
rarely that person like i'm very
collaborative and and
then was also with this to a point but
ultimately it was
i don't see it that way and i got to see
it the way i see it and so finally
a fella named chip mosher who works for
comixology he had previously been at
boom and they've been a dark horse as a
publicist for a long time
was running the originals banner
comixology and he says well do you have
a story that you've always wanted to
tell like something you've just been
keeping in the barn in your back pocket
but a thing that means something to you
i'm like well yeah
i got this thing and like sent him you
know 100-page script and the 25-page
you know treatment and the pitches and
all that stuff
he's like yeah we'll do it and and that
was about two years ago we announced it
at comic-con
2019 um and it took a while
but uh but it dropped last week it
dropped on father's day
week
really really beautiful yes
um it's digital only it's digital only
for
its digital premiere it will be in print
next
march uh march 1st 2022
uh just in time for autism awareness
week [ __ ] hey man
nice how can uh
how can the folks here in this room and
the folks at home get to it
if you're a comixology unlimited
subscriber you get it for free if you
have amazon prime you can read it for
free if you have kindle unlimited you
can read it for free
um because amazon it turns out has all
the money
and they kind of don't really need yours
um
but if you are a member of none of those
things you can go on amazon or
comixology and you can buy it for like
seven bucks
and uh and yeah it means it means the
world to me it means the world to me
that people have been responding as
kindly as they have
um you know it means the world to me
that the people who've read it have
said such kind things about it you know
we had we were able to slip it to some
people early and like damon lindelof
wrote the introduction for the book
beautiful um neil gaiman gave us a big
shiny blurb for it
gail simone and joe henderson who ran
lucifer never heard
any of these people yeah they're all
strangers
um but yeah it's uh it has been it's
been the weirdest most wonderful
month to to both have the the the
kickstarter
coming to fruition and doing as well as
it did to have this book hit the world
kind of at the same time um it has been
uh
it has been a lovely lovely week um so
to everybody here
thank you
[Applause]
good things happen to good people you're
a good person uh we try you were due
um all right bamf oh man one other thing
that the chat is screaming about which i
think we're in a youtube
are they screaming about this fine
skywalker ranch
young farmer lucas bruno wine before
it's time
um we're in a uniquely uh
position a unique position to talk about
this so maybe we don't want it
but there was uh a controversy around
batman
this past week
yes should we address
that uh the chat's dying to hear about
do we want to skip it we can i can as
the producer of the show i can just say
we're not going there
i think we should like batman like we're
not going there yeah doesn't go there
because that's what heroes do and then
zack snyder
sent a tweet out and just said canon so
why don't we talk about zack's tweet
instead of
zach's tweet uh was graphic as [ __ ]
it included artwork a little background
um
the the folks from the harley quinn um
animated series
had done an interview i want to say it
was with variety talking about the
things that they could and couldn't do
an interference they might have had from
the
from the higher ups and they mentioned
that uh dc
had uh ixnade a scene in the harley
quinn
animated series in which um batman would
have
um given moral pleasure gone down on
catwoman
we're all adults here say it the dirty
way
had uh had would have displayed his
proficiency in cunnilingus
to to catwoman right um which like
would track for the character he's great
at everything i mean he studied it all
he's traveling the world
he studied everything he went all around
the world you telling me he'd leave that
off the list
you know he went somewhere and met the
lick master who's like fugging
like sam kinnison said lick the alphabet
and [ __ ] he went home a smarter wiser
man
and so dc's response to this attempted
scene was um
batman would never do that because
that's not what heroes do heroes don't
do that
i mean isn't that the idea is like
i would imagine i would imagine only a
villain's like i'm not gonna eat your
[ __ ]
because i'm a villain i got no time but
a [ __ ] hero that's what a hero does
hero eat your [ __ ] before you do
anything before you even see his dick
and in batman's case that takes a long
time because he's a layered character
right i'm just really glad that thomas
and martha wayne weren't around to see
this
you don't think they look you don't
think they're looking down from heaven
and watching their [ __ ] son
they're like finally he's happy and uh
uh look as a guy who's been reading
batman his whole life and uh
he was given stewardship once or twice
but take for you know
take it with a grain of salt i did make
him pee his pants as well and the
internet hates that
um i of course [ __ ] batman he's [ __ ]
i uh
i wrote a story about him and silver
saint cloud
all they did was [ __ ] like a big part of
the story was they would just go to an
island that he owned and parrot key to
[ __ ] and then he'd fly back to gotham to
like fight crime all the time
and i remember at one point when we were
working on it they were like there's an
awful lot of sex in this
i'm like hey man logically speaking if
every night of your [ __ ] life
you were putting it on the line dressed
like this for total strangers and almost
getting killed
each and every [ __ ] time you know
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
hard like [ __ ] what are you doing it
for he's like i could die at any minute
like let's do it you should so
i was like of course he's [ __ ] hyper
sexualized and this is somebody's
he's always loved and whatnot so there
was a little pushback but not
not like that i mean i read that article
i didn't get the impression that the
harley quinn writers were bitching
because
lord knows they get away with everything
it's a wonderfully vile show it's
[ __ ]
nuts what they get away with and i was i
was i was like they pushed back on
cunnilingus
how [ __ ] quaint because the [ __ ] they
do get away with on that show
is absolute [ __ ] nuts man like it
still remains the one show that i watch
where i'm like
i should have pitched this
how did i not pitch this um
so yeah in my estimation absolutely
batman
goes down he's just he's a gentleman he
was raised right they haven't [ __ ]
like and he understands he's like he's
the kind of guy
think about it he saw his parents
[ __ ] killed in crime alley
and he was like this will never [ __ ]
happen to someone else
somewhere along the line he probably met
some woman who didn't come and he was
like this will never [ __ ] happen to
someone else
so he spent his life just like ah
see i i feel like he's indiana jones
that way
which is like he will go down on you and
then fall asleep after you're done
because it's not the years honey it's
the mileage true and that's a sleepy ass
man who just [ __ ] fought on that yeah
that's a hero like he doesn't need it as
much as he needs you to have it
he and hill i remember one of my
favorite things reading batman and
comics years ago was
he only needs three hours of sleep at
night so
come on
guy ain't even sleeping you wind up in
bed with him he's the kind of guy that's
like you up
you up are you still up and you're like
we [ __ ] did it already he's like i
could die
tomorrow night i could [ __ ] die at
the business end
of a question mark shaped gun
please let's do one more round let's do
it let's do it here comes the bat pull
like slide down i mean there are two
reasons why
there's no fabric on this part exactly
one so the police know he's a white guy
and two so we can go down on
batman is throbbing
[Laughter]
uh yeah man as if anyone gives a [ __ ]
what i think i
i i've of course come on nobody ever
[ __ ] thought like what's the mall
rats guy think
does he think batman eat [ __ ] yeah
batman needs lots of [ __ ]
so much [ __ ] yeah i think my
my two favorite responses were the zack
snyder like tweeting
a picture an illustration that
apparently he might have had
commissioned
of batman going down on catwoman with
the phrase canon
yeah and uh and somebody i can't
remember who the [ __ ] it was who's like
i didn't expect
to discover that batman and dj khaled
had something in common today
but okay here we go
um i thought it was like you know wow in
my lifetime
i'm not gonna i ain't taking any sort of
responsibility but like i have been
talking about stupid [ __ ] like this for
like nearly 30 years and i'm like wow i
believe
in some small way i may have shifted the
cultural discussion
into a place that i find interesting you
know when i was a kid it was like sports
and politics and now people are like
you think batman hates [ __ ]
let's see what time magazine thinks time
has a feeling about it
no doubt um all right um
what uh what what uh what are we doing
banff man
um we could do q a
do we have our prizes lined up well i
don't know what's in that box
i know what's in my box you got some
[ __ ] yeah you got better [ __ ] than i do
let's uh clear the bar this [ __ ]
lucas guy is getting a lot of air time
i wanna i wanna i wanna go to the park
though i wanna go to rise of the
resistance so let the man know that i
like the shoe
that's true that's true well look at
that [ __ ] kids
look at that someone's gonna [ __ ]
walk away with this tonight somebody's
walking away
with a diamond select toys milestones
edition
of baby yoda or the child as he's called
and also it's not just the box we've
been a lot about just empty boxes
tonight
a thing is in the box this is a [ __ ]
actual item it looks like the picture
that you're seeing on the box man from
gentle giant
limited that's going to be one of the
prizes tonight if uh you answer
uh a question um and or if you ask us a
question
that's it yeah it's our job yeah we
answer what else we got
what's in here i don't know satin
jackets oh look at this [ __ ] kids
this is a satin jacket from the good
folks at chalk line
and it's from powercon which is the
he-man convention
look at this [ __ ] i don't know if you
know this or not but he-man is coming
back and [ __ ]
masters universe is back it's an extra
large ladies and gentlemen
powercon jacket uh exclusive and stuff
so that's another thing we could win
tonight
what about this [ __ ] [ __ ] back
here look at this
this is
now mind you kids this is before you get
all excited
it's a broken batman maquette but it
came from the warner brothers store this
is a limited number they only made 250
artists proof
and this is number 165. uh batman's
as you can see one of his ears has been
chipped but
from clever people clever people can fix
it and [ __ ] so that's
one of the prizes tonight we got three
three things there
i've also got other [ __ ] in here let's
see um
i've got oh what's this the good folks
at uh is that also a thing what's that
different thing
oh here we go well this is
that's a yeah that's a booby prize not a
booby prize but it's a bonus
there's a falcon in the winter soldier
shirt
that came from the premium and stuff
fangirl gift
yes this is kind of dope man there's a
fangoria
bag and a fangoria t-shirt i'm working
on something with fangoria
so they sent me right did you work there
i worked there
how long uh i was there from 94.
magazine shaped my [ __ ] world when i
was a child 94-96 i was a consulting
editor of fangoria
oh okay man that's right i knew that
again
right out the bottle
[Applause]
jc mark just bought the whole bottle
all right so we got [ __ ] to give out
what we're going to do tonight
is uh what's the banff man tell them the
rules we came up
tell them what we're doing bam all right
here we go
uh so for the last 15 months we've been
taking questions only from
online and now and giving away no prizes
and giving away nothing
and now we have a room full of people so
what we're going to do is we're going to
do two questions from
this audience and one from youtube
and the youtube question is uh playing
for
an audience member tonight uh we we did
a little survey before the show
started and uh the the person who will
be winning the prize from the youtube
chat
is um the the person who has never been
to a fat man beyond show
who is also the oldest person who in
here who has never been to f and beyond
so he'll be coming up to claim claim his
prize after
uh i read the question kids we didn't
open it here but [ __ ] uh we opened it
a few weeks ago
this is a big old amazon uh box for uh
the uh
[ __ ] uh uh whatchamacallit invincible
thank you i smoked it away sorry
uh a big old invincible uh box that
doesn't have
it's got a bunch of wrapping in it but
it is a box ladies and gentlemen
and as my mother said a box is useful
for many things so before we get started
who wants the invincible box it's
beautiful come get it
it's all yours go look at right in that
camera and be like i love
trash
well done man give it up i'm a trash
panda
um all right i love how we just get rid
of i'm gonna use this show to get rid of
a lot of [ __ ] in my life and whatnot
but come with pets and be like who wants
a dog
um all right all right jc back to you
okay do we want to start with youtube or
end with youtube
let's start with youtube and what is the
youtube prize
we we haven't decided that this should
be the grand prize
so the youtube prize no no okay
because the youtube prize the person on
youtube does all the work
and then somebody just gets a [ __ ]
thing for free that's fair
feels like you got to come up with a
good enough question so we'll figure it
out at the
at the end like who who was the best
question i like kicking the can down the
road i think so figuring this [ __ ] out
i think that's the way to do it man so
after we do the three questions at the
end of the night we'll figure out
who won what that makes more sense all
right
uh randomly like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna have
to compete i wasn't prepared to compete
but yeah
i guess it is a bit of a competition
willing to stab themselves for a [ __ ]
pen
before that's true there wasn't nearly a
fight for a loki pen
so [ __ ] all right man hit us okay a
random hero
in youtube chat asked in light of
father's day
name your favorite tv father and why
um in light of father's day my favorite
tv father hands down
dan connor from the old run of
roseanne i know uh i'm not way familiar
with the current run i watched a little
bit
but the old run i watched roseanne like
when i was
younger at this quick stop like watched
every episode
dan connor to me was the ultimate uh
dad and uh thank god [ __ ]
we shared a kind of a size
in common because i remember like my
wife told me at one point i was like
what did you find
attractive about me she's like you
reminded me of dan connor
and i got to tell john goodman that i
told goody that when we were working on
red state and he was like which one's
your wife
so dan connor man john goodman is the
great dan connor
um and uh i won't touch the controversy
of whether he's alive or not because he
remember he died in the old version of
the show
but they brought him back thank god i'll
watch him
do anything although i stopped watching
the show so i guess i'm full of [ __ ]
um but i will eventually catch up with
the rest of the episodes anyway
dan connor over to you um i have two
answers
okay ooh we get two my sub answer is
james senior from good times
ooh that's a good one yeah yeah it's
bigger he was big father figure in my
life even though i had a father
i liked i liked james senior he was damn
in florida
yeah he was very you could tell he was
very physical and [ __ ] like those kids
were obedient because he was just so
[ __ ] imposing and scary and [ __ ]
uh first one is giles
from buffy the vampire slayer
[Applause]
who is not actually buffy's father he's
he's a librarian
watcher he's a father figure but that
idea that
for people who may not have fathers in
their lives that they could find that
person elsewhere
that that show was about lots of things
but for me chiefly it's about the family
that you
build along the way right and for giles
to care as much as he did for buffy
expecting so little in return other than
for her to be
her best self um speaks very much to the
kind of father that
that deserves to exist in the world
excellent answer i never would have
[ __ ] thought of that or picked that
and [ __ ]
and the other one only because
everything that he did he
like he made every right decision even
though it might have not turned out the
way he wanted to
but tywin lannister on game of thrones
knew how to run [ __ ]
you better walk us through this one man
i i just think of him as the worst dad
he tried to kill his kid all
right listen this kid shot him in the
[ __ ] he hated him so much
they were all bitch-ass kids and so
yeah you gotta whip some [ __ ]
into shape but like
he ran the lannister family he was the
bank of the [ __ ] westeros like he had
his [ __ ]
right until he got killed in the [ __ ]
until he got killed in the [ __ ] which
ain't his fault
like some [ __ ] [ __ ] kid just
shows up and plugs you in the chest
while you're taking a crap
it's true he got menendezed in his own
bathroom you know
like i what too [ __ ] soon
[ __ ] happened during clerks kids all i'm
saying is we [ __ ] on tywin lannister the
same way we should on the empire in star
wars
yeah but the empire was very well run
like
all oh my god is your argument like the
trains ran on time
i'm just saying everybody knew what they
were doing you don't get a galactic
empire that you can keep going for a
long time like by accident
my focus knew what they were doing it's
true so tywin lannister
you know he had some knucklehead kids
and tried to whip him into shape i
remember a bunch of people gathered in a
beer hall and some guy saying crazy [ __ ]
that only made sense to a few
and then a bunch of people died so shut
the [ __ ] up man
what was your was that both of them i
gave you
giles and i gave you tywin fair enough
we got two
we got two it's a good question i don't
know if it wins the yoda though
that's the online question right that's
the online so it's definitely not
winning the [ __ ] yoga oh damn
all right do i bamf in during q a
i would bam it's your it's your [ __ ]
trademark man but the thing is that he
hasn't banffed away like the banff was
always the
presence it's true and if he's here but
it's cutting to him like if you watch
the
show it cuts from us tim so every time
it cuts to him like now it should be
damn fancy yeah
see i don't watch the show because i'm
in the show
that's your next t-shirt i don't watch
the show because i'm in the show
okay uh this is really weird i was about
to read the question then i realized
this person's in the room now
with us so i can actually call jake w
up come on up jake jake w
jakey here all right
jake
first of all thanks for being back guys
it's my first time here so it's awesome
seeing you guys you never been here
before
no so what do you think it's awesome
i've been here uh in the bar but not
with you guys
during the show and i've been watching
for years and uh
just awesome being here so thank you
welcome coming out man
so my question is in honor of loki being
the first marvel villain to get his own
show
what dc villain would you want to see
get their own show
speaking of loki you look like little
hemsworth man like very
you look like for the early years man i
was going
yeah really like thorin high school you
got that going on
thank you um you want to take this uh
i'm thinking
uh okay i got it
go um and it's it's it might be a cheat
because we're getting it
okay but uh catwoman like give
give me the the [ __ ] heist every week
give me the
like kind of on the run from batman and
the gcpd give me the girl who's kind of
trying to make her own way in a city
that has no time for her space for her
um and give me the woman who's trying to
build her own family
of street urchins you know and take care
of them at the same time
i mean you get all of the joys of like
leverage plus
you know [ __ ] cop shows plus i don't
know
again party of five all at once
i like it i'd watch that so keep making
it warner brothers
well i have this why would that be on
[Applause]
we gotta go back to our little boxes on
the internet and [ __ ] where there's no
alcohol yeah well there's no booze just
we work
[Laughter]
um okay the question is uh who gets a
loki show that's not loki
in the dc universe in the dcu very
specific
my go-to response for every [ __ ] dc
thing is always the question
so i won't go to that it's like my
citizen kane of response not a bad guy
i'm sorry i i hate to interrupt i was
just what dc villain
since it loki's the first marvel villain
to get his own show fair
all right so it can't be the question
anyway you're already [ __ ] on my
dreams
um in this make pretend game it has to
be very specific i understand
um all right let's see what villain
would i like to watch on a regular basis
um hmm i mean
joker's a little obvious um
two faces you know i would get irritated
the two puns would get tired so [ __ ]
quick although dude
that's a low and order show
yeah he's both sides he's both [ __ ]
sides it's true
he could run for [ __ ] presents to
face
[Music]
you can't handle you can't handle the
truth
well done man thank you um let me see
condiment king i don't know if i could
watch that he's like a guest star but
who would i really like to watch
every week now
not deathstroke is we've seen a lot of
him and we've seen a lot of bane
who zazz
mr zazz well victor zazz like his whole
thing is like i cut myself after i kill
people
so every show we just watch it's like
dexter
we've seen that show um
god man i mean of course you're tempted
to say harley i could watch her
but they do that already um more or less
with the cartoon
well i was gonna say clayface because he
could be
anybody right so like you know you can
shapeshift and you could tell all sorts
of different stories
plus he could be like a good guy in most
of them right like
he has to kind of come correct or
something like that i got another one
go save me go did you ever see there was
a show on fox i want to say it was like
late 90s early 2000s it's called profit
yeah with adrian pastgar about this sort
of business kid who's also a sociopath
but that's how he rises he's very like
you know american psycho
right um but i feel like you could do a
lex luthor
show i feel like you can do like the the
the business magnate like it
it could be dynasty if you want it to be
dynasty but it also be you know the
story of a young
[ __ ] villain who's clawing up his you
know out of the shadow of his own dad
and trying to make his way in business
and
what does jeff bezos do with all that
money that's true
crime maybe amazon can [ __ ] hear it
um
i uh yeah i'd watch that luther it's
weird i went right to batman villains
that's true guys hello alice
um luther giving the kryptonite bullet
to
bloodsport hmm
i love i love when i go real deep where
i'm like [ __ ] the show i'm thinking
as if the answer really matters all that
much do you want me to do another one
[ __ ] yeah look at you you're full of
them i'm full of them
um amanda waller
you know i mean i know we get like
suicide squad shows but i think that
[ __ ] woman
um and her story and how she gets to be
that person that she is
you know and it's probably some kind of
dual timeline show where you get to see
the rise of amanda waller and then
amanda [ __ ] waller and task force x
and doing awful [ __ ]
but tell you get me esopathy mercury on
the phone
it's boring but i think i might go
riddler i really gave this some serious
consideration you go
pretty far with that character not just
like in [ __ ] you know the riddle of
the week and [ __ ]
but also like why why is he such an
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
why is that your shtick and whatnot the
question of our times
yeah then you can take them dark like he
tries to go dark in the beginning but
they're like come on stop it you're too
cute
and then he has to change up they're
making new riddler though he's gonna be
mean right batman the batman matt reed
based he's got a lot of tape on his head
and [ __ ] i mean you could also do the
riddler game show
it doesn't have to be a drama the
riddler is a host of a game show
and if you lose you die but still that'd
be a compelling [ __ ] game
like who wouldn't watch it like did you
watch a game show last night somebody
died like it happens every week let's
press your luck
starring the riddler riddle me this
wouldn't it be called that oh that's
that's good um yeah he gave you like
nine answers i gave you one mine was not
as strong as any of his but still
that's that's how this show rolls thank
you
well done give it up for you gotta give
him a prize
oh yeah well we'll do it afterwards okay
so jc you got to remember the question
so we can dole out the prizes
bamf banff man's back kids if you could
live
on any oh hold on i screwed this up it's
like when you guys call the show
fat man on batman i just did that that
was my version of
yeah uh frenchie frenchie where are you
at
frenchie give it up for frenchie
everybody
all right
[Applause]
so if you could live on any planet in
the star wars universe
which one would it be and why uh hoth
because i'm a layers man
[Laughter]
now that that [ __ ] long wool coat
would come in handy on [ __ ] hot and
stuff
and i don't like to cut open taunton so
i brought my own layers
how about you what plant are you um i'm
a city boy so i think i'm going to
coruscant
ooh and also like they seem to have a
relatively temperate
weather you got a better idea than that
they got air conditioning there
you gotta change my answer you got
restaurants yeah i [ __ ] went to like
an ice cave and [ __ ] with [ __ ] wild
animals outside it'll take you
the worst season of survival
because i wanted to wear my coat but
you're right i could wear it of course
like at all sorts of ceremonially
because they dress funny though they do
but like you got restaurants and
nightclubs and a weird 50s diner in the
middle of nowhere
and like jedi children's waiting to be
killed [ __ ] sold me man
let's go done and done his answer is
better i mean naboo is nice though
no is it yeah underwater no that's just
the water part of naboo but they [ __ ]
got like
forests and castles and [ __ ] it's the
amafi coast
make up your mind then where do you want
to live i'm just saying you're like
like i told you where to go you're
coming up with so many good options
you're talking to the snow guy
i'm staying with carson i'm sticking for
the city planet i like it but i like
your backup plan
you like those answers yeah well done so
excellent well done give it up for
francis
she frenched us
all right man this is the the last
question so so far we have no
it's three and frenchy test conditions
three oh so there's three plus the
online one well we have the online and
then two
so we're we're ready to judge okay so
we've got one more to go
well the online one don't get to win
right
he's winning for somebody else he's
winning for somebody in the room they
get like a door prize or some so [ __ ]
i'm sorry we made these rules up 10
minutes before the show began
and we literally did have a discussion
about the rules um but yeah so we got
so like the fangoria shirt and the
fangoria
bag will be the online winner cat
okay the person the youtube question and
the
somebody wanted here was like 50 or
something yeah this
this guy right here come on up get your
prize kiddo
this is your first time here look at
that camera and be like first time
people really win on fat man beyonce
there you go give it up for him our true
winner
[Applause]
and he won because somebody on the
internet asked a question
what a t-ball win that was man well done
he just walked away
with some free [ __ ] yeah really um all
right so we got one
we got two and we got three and this is
a small thing so
we still have one more question okay one
more question all right
next one is uh kevin conroy kevin
carmore give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
how's it going how are you man i'm doing
great i got this thing
this is what you're playing for this
hoodie i got for free tonight
no i'm keeping this i got one at home i
know i figured
all right what uh what what's your what
are you feeling so
i wanted to know who's your superhero
hall pass
superhero hall pass i know who won the
top prize
what a great question superhero hall
pass
this is a tough one because my wife is
like super [ __ ] jealous so even if i
was like
that's true she doesn't watch the show
so i can answer honestly
um oh damn
oh man there's so many
like i think you wanted you know what it
might be clay face
[Laughter]
because clay face could be anybody you
want man like you [ __ ]
clay face you'd be like oh my god clay
face i've always wanted to have sex with
robert de niro clay face is like you
talking to me
yeah i'm going with clay face man clay
face is the it's a strong call
i'm just thinking of that scene in the
boys where uh
where where the legit just [ __ ] does
that
it's like i want her back man just be
the girl i just want to [ __ ]
milk her a bit i want to do it i want a
homelander treatment
yeah wow that is a strong position
to take i like it dirty muddy doesn't
get dirtier with the
clay face oh [ __ ]
my god think about it with clay face you
could be like clay face i want to [ __ ]
abe lincoln tonight
you [ __ ] hat and all he'll do it for
you and [ __ ] four strokes and seven
years ago
and he would be up for the challenge
because he's an actor
like he likes acting like do you want
young abe lincoln or do you want like
old president
oh my god he's like i could give you a
range of abe
yes you were like i'm a young guy you
don't [ __ ] pull this thing on the
river
or do you want homeside civil war is
that your [ __ ] abe lincoln a young
guy on the river
it sounded like [ __ ] yoda well no
he's got the weird really high voice
remember when
that's right yeah that's how daniel
daley did him like all the research was
that he actually sounded a bit like this
yeah you don't look like that on mount
rushmore but
yeah she sure sounded like that yes
apparently chipmunk
um i'm stalling here because i figured
it's a tana she's magic she's got
fishnets
that's magic in and of itself yeah i
mean like because my
my default is just to go [ __ ] wonder
woman because that would
what mystique does the same thing as
clay face
true jesus i could have went with
mystique and i went for the guy
really is very revealing about me i
didn't bump into that at all
no i was like we'll just move his dick
out of the way
give me a rake we'll get rid of that
guys are you sure you don't want
mystique i'm like you
clay face i like it dirty
bam i'll throw mine out what about
elastigirl
from the incredibles that just seems fun
fun and fun in what way i mean i mean
she can contort to any position any
shape
and if you need her to have a dick she
can have one
why would i want that
[Laughter]
just saying um i guess yeah i guess
uh yeah cause she could be all sorts of
like all over the place
i think we're all being very revealing
about our sex lives based on the things
we want apparently jc wants somebody
acrobatic in the bedroom
martial i want somebody to dominate me
like
hey wonder woman my dick is afraid of
you an apparently
great i'm looking for a guy
um boyle boy yeah you're very fluid yeah
yeah
i'm like loki man there you go loki it's
not [ __ ]
i'm still doing it um did that answer
yeah yeah you're satisfied by that one
give it up for kev that's a great
question keep on revealing [ __ ] we
shouldn't reveal
all right okay how are you feeling well
we've got three
prizes to give out um let's uh well
let's figure out uh what was i
i'm gonna i can't i'm biased so what do
you think the best question
um okay so we had frenchie tuscadero who
asked about
um the planets to live on in hoth
frenchy how old are you do you even get
that reference
no it's [ __ ] happy there was a
character on a tv
show like 400 years ago
called happy days her name was pinky
tuscadero but i really appreciated the
reference yeah
um so that was which plan the star wars
universe we want to live on yes i don't
remember where
draft dodger thor was what his question
was
dodger thor [ __ ] this war man
uh say who dad drafted after thor he
asked the question that you gave
96 answers to the villain that we wanted
to uh
what loki who gets a loki show but dc
villain gets a loki show
and then kevin conroy was uh which dc
lady did we
which superhero lady he didn't even say
lady
that's true because you interpreted that
as that's why i was just like oh [ __ ]
man
i'm sex positive what's bane doing
i mean he comes with drugs yes dominate
me
take some of this
we're doing poppers and just getting
wild um
all right i feel like uh we get
you know we should probably hand it over
to jc to make those decisions
he owns the bar seems a little [ __ ] up
but sure yeah yeah how you make
everybody mad and then you guys leave
and then they're like
yeah yeah peace out you're waiting for
me when i get back
really wanted that jacket dude um
so we had uh the the loki
question the dc loki we had
um the star wars biome star wars
where do you want to live where and the
other okay i think
do we do do we announce the top prize or
do we go and reverse like do we
say like third place second place
bottoms up as like i'd say to clay face
bottoms up [ __ ]
power bottom okay i gotta say well
we all got to come out and have a good
night after a
long coven break
and so we're all winners because we're
all winners that
absolutely so third place is really just
the third
first place winner that's true um and
don't forget we gave away a lot of empty
boxes tonight
would you like a thing to put in your
box yes
let's say um
star wars habitat is
our first third place
our third first place winner so third
place franchie
frenchy we're gonna uh you could
what do you want you tell me what you
want i'll tell you if i could do it
you want the batman let's check with who
probably the first place winner is going
to be
what would you take
it's okay she can have the batman batman
jeers come get it fred jay
this batman stood proudly in my house
until he broke and then like [ __ ] toy
story i said get out of here
he's like my jesse yeah i can [ __ ]
sign it if you like
sure he's looking at me like when he
loved me
where do you want me to sign right here
well it's you're selling black on black
bro i am starting to blog
you want me to go on the chest right on
the nipples it's probably going to
devalue it but here we go
how did it break uh i blamed shecky
hit the shelf and it went down and i
love the dog so i never said anything
boom give it up for frenchie she won
[Applause]
people really win here all right and
then i think uh
thor's stunt double stunt double is
getting a powercon
jacket come get it
[Applause]
one of a kind man thank the good folks
at chalk line
oh and everybody gets a poster from nate
also is that right although
our winners not everybody all the
winners sorry all the winners get forgot
to say that
potent poster sorry and nate did
i lied we do have a gorgeous apologies
piece of artwork for this week's show
everybody's a winner but that's not true
pass that off to frenchie
pass that off to the mighty thor and
then of course
last but not least walking away
it's batman with baby yoda as batman
himself give it up for kevin conroy
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
uh okay we got here a uh what size
uh large falcon and the winter soldier
shirt
[Applause]
i know oh it comes with this too there's
a unless you don't want it this is a
this is a print um
91 of 300. yeah yeah
oh my god does anybody need some toned
balls
that's right we have ball toner right
there look at that people walk away with
[ __ ] who needs some
good folks bald friends at manscape
ladies and gentlemen young lady you do
not have balls
what you won something didn't you
greedy sit the [ __ ] down
um who wants some ball [ __ ] ladies
there's a man and he wants [ __ ]
well done um we also have well we can
save this for saturday don't forget we
have a show
on saturday kids the seats are sold out
so i'm sure we'll see some of you there
we've got no there's uh nine tickets
left for saturday so if you had fun
tonight
uh what is it uh
fatman626.eventbrite.com
that's where they can find it yeah 626
is the date so fatman626.eventbrite.com
saturday is the show what's up saturday
at 2pm
so saturday at 2 o'clock kids there's a
few tickets left
uh at a very long [ __ ] address uh
yeah go to csmod.com thank you very much
nate um
what else can we tell you uh smod castle
grand opening if you're anywhere back
east or if you're
here in the west and you're willing to
travel baggies uh july
9th 10th and 11th uh tickets for that
are at seasmod.com as well
um what else i think that's it tell them
about your shirt where can they get that
shirt we're gonna get this be humble
that [ __ ] no shirt
embattledclothing.com use the code mark
15 to save 15
off your first order ladies and
gentlemen of the scum and villainy
cantina who we have not seen in 15
[ __ ] months
have you had a good time this evening
[Applause]
what a way to [ __ ] return man you
made us feel so
[ __ ] well there are two women waiting
for us at home are gonna get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of them tonight because
we're coming home like conquering
champions because you made us feel
so [ __ ] special thank you for coming
out tonight give it up for the man
without whom
we don't get to do a show man it's his
[ __ ] bar
he's banff man himself
scum and villainy cantina is now open
every damn day and stuff uh do they have
to make reservations
no just come on in just come on in come
and enjoy the place uh even when we're
not doing the show but we do have a show
on saturday so if you're at home going
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do with my
weekend
here's a little bit of shape to your
weekend two two o'clock is that one
two o'clock door's at noon doors at noon
early lunar one
started at eight o'clock tonight what
time did people arrive
six you made people wait two [ __ ]
hours
we're so sorry why don't you go if i if
i was you i'd come at like 7 30.
never be tricked again and [ __ ] um
that's right care for the chicken
fingers that's right
i forgot there's also the chicken i
always assume we're the show but some
people like we came to drink idiot
you're just
you're in the world and also seating's
first come first serve
oh is that right oh oh my god so it's
like a [ __ ] blood sport to get in
here
we don't see this we don't see the dark
underbelly all we ever see is the bright
lights and the happy
and the human feces in the alley well we
see that as well
not so much anymore uh we don't get to
do this ladies and gentlemen
uh unless uh somebody says i'll be the
one not wearing a funny hat god damn it
give it up for [ __ ] marvelous mark
bernard
and that for the first time in 15 months
is fat man beyond man i'm kevin smith i
am mark bernard tune in next time same
fat time save fat
kevin smith jeff's kiss everybody
welcome back
[Applause]
you